Good Morning John, I'm sorry about your face.
I wanted to make a video for you, uh, to make
you feel better, and I didn't know which kind
to make, so I asked Twitter if I should do
a rant video or a joke video.
And man was it overwhelmingly in favor of
rants.
Why do you need to see me get angry instead
of be funny?!
Is the negative cognitive bias so prevalent
in our society, and in our brains, that we
can't just have a good time?
So, that was my first one.
Let's talk about driving for a second.
If you, uh, text while you're driving and
you say 'well it's okay, cause I'm really
good at it and I'm really careful.'
What you're really saying is: 'Well, I haven't
killed anyone...yet.'
Don't!
Stop, just don't stop, believing.
Where did I...what's happening?
This also goes for if you're waiting at a
light, especially if you're the first in line
and you're looking at your text message and
the light's green.
Now in this situation, I will honk at you.
This is not an excuse to get angry at me,
because you were the one not driving at a
green light!
I apologize for being so rude to you, I guess
I should have just sat there...forever...literally.
Speaking of people who are incapable of not
looking at their phones every two seconds,
if that's you that's fine, but don't go to
movies.
Just never do it.
There's other ways to be entertained than
watching a movie while checking Facebook with
your brighter than the sun cellphone.
Topic change: People who mock others for their
choice of major in school.
Especially because it's almost always science
people, like myself, going after humanities
people.
I'm sorry to bring this up, but interacting
with and creating for other humans is one
of the only things that computers are not
getting really, really good at really fast.
So humanities jobs are actually pretty safe
from being automated away, so maybe don't
be so entitled.
Also people who mock others for using words
like "bae" or "boo" or "slay:" look, language
is fluid, and subcultures define themselves
by using slang terms; you do that too.
What you're really saying when you complain
about other people's slang words is: 'my subculture
is better than yours.'
Which of course you do believe,;we all believe
that, but getting up on your soapbox and shouting
about it makes you look pretentious and patronizing.
So, yeah, if your definition of rant is just
complaining about people who happen to be
different from you: you're a big bag of farts.
Do you run a website?
Are you thinking about requiring the users
of that website to do something?
Do not ask them if they would like to do that
thing if you're going to require it.
Because if I"m asked, and I click 'no, I don't
want to do that.'
And then the website says 'okay, we'll ask
again later.'
That's not a good user experience!'
Like all cars have screens in them now.
I don't have a car like this but all the new
ones do.
Here's what I've noticed, instead of using
the absolutely free and wonderful Android
operating system, car companies have insisted
on creating their own operating systems and
software.
And the software is awful!
Congratulations on making a brand new car
feel like a first generation iPhone.
The software is so unresponsive, you hit a
button and then it's like 'Oh, let me think
about that for a second.'
And then you're like, did you register that
I hit the button?'
So you hit it a few more times.
And then the software is like 'Oh, let me
register all of those punches in sequence
on multiple screens as we go through.
Even though you couldn't see these things
when you were hitting the buttons.'
And suddenly you've reached some obscure place
inside the software, and you've lowered your
dash lights in a way that you'll never be
able to figure out how to undo.
Hey if somebody is like, "Please don't use
that word in that way; it makes me feel bad
about myself."
How about you don't get all defensive, and
start defending yourse--just don't use that
word in that way because it makes them feel
bad about themselves!
Now if you've ever talked about leveraging
online influencers to connect with digital
natives through mobile snack-able content,
you're fired.
Just go to your desk, get your stuff, leave.
I went to school for like 85 years and no
one ever taught me how to do my taxes.
What?
What the?!
Why wouldn't you?!
School's paid for by the government, and they
want you to pay taxes.
Why wouldn't they teach you that?
Also, I know how to do long division...why?
Why do I know how to solve a quadratic equation
without knowing what a quadratic equation
is?
Wha?
Maybe that should have been the time when
you were teaching me how to do my taxes.
Also cursive writing, do they still do that?
Because, ugh, I was so bad at it and I spent
so much of life learning how to do this thing
that I've never done.
And finally, my final rant of this rant video:
cable news.
Ughhh.
Thanks for watching John.
I hope you enjoyed it and I'll see you on
Tuesday.
You can watch my first rant video over there,
also the giraffe love design is back except
with better colors - it's shiny, and we got
new tank tops for summer.